[Music]
my name is Dylan Dell from Google cloud
and I'm a Technical Account Manager and
lead for one of our largest customer at
Google cloud my colleague technical
infrastructure leaves swathi here is
with me today to lead a session together
as you may have noticed the title of our
session is when aspirations meets
reality at Google Cloud we have variety
of large and complex projects going on
and we wanted to share the types of the
challenges that we've been experiencing
and also have been evolving to make
migrations successful specifically with
some of our customers who've been with
us close to one year throughout their
journey there have been many aspirations
around what we wanted to achieve such as
new technology adoptions and products
and we wanted to share what was the
reality during the implementation and
how we address the roadblocks we will
open our conversation by sharing the
approach and examples then discuss what
we learned and apply for our customers
here is our agenda for today we'll share
the following first a high-level view
around the customer migration journey at
Google cloud second our migration
approach third aspiration versus reality
and is rational and finally how it
revised our guiding principles to
reflect our learnings from the past
after sharing those new guiding
principles we'll open our session for
Q&A so journey for migration when you
think about the cloud migration journey
it may sound simple like another
migration approach but there are many
factors to consider including how we are
going to discover and identify some of
the key workload how we are going to
plan and design an architect the future
design and also planning design how
we're going to deploy those things when
you deploy those workload how you're
going to execute and optimize as we
operate the environment
these topics are relevant across
technology organization and support
structure and processes we understand
that it requires a lot of work and there
are many areas for consideration lots of
late-night food and coffee of course and
staying in the office till midnight or
late night troubleshooting issues the
mistake that we have made in the past
and also improving and supporting what
was previously implemented the third
picture in the left is our lead engineer
Jose in the office probably around like
4:00 a.m. troubleshooting the issue with
an engineer in Sydney it appears that
this is very kind of common sight in
that migration projects I think that we
ended up probably staying until 6 a.m.
to solve the issue so big shout out for
Jose for support to cover all these
topics outlined here we probably need
another whole day to cover that instead
today we will hyper focus our topics in
technology during the plan and deploy
face this way we'll be able to share
more specific examples for you which you
can apply for your own organizations
immediately so let's talk about some of
those high-level approach first before
we get into the more details we talked
about those four stages of the customer
migration journey in the previous slide
this these stages get repeated in each
phase of our migration approach for the
migration approach this is an example of
how we view the world of complete cloud
migration beginning from building the
foundation layer to migrate the key
workload to cloud as a hybrid
architecture and building the full data
center capability in TCP and finally
moving data and retiring some of those
on-prem data centers let's double-click
each one of those phase 1 I'm sorry
phase 0 this is kind of where we build
our court GCP foundational components
and validate key assumptions the goal of
this phase is to build a component so
that it can be ready for future
migration phase 1 is where we migrate
selected workload and build automations
around GCP deployment this can be
considered as
hybrid architecture the goal of this
phase to ensure that on prim
architecture works with the cloud and
begin to leverage clouds for selective
workload and Phase two is this is where
we build full datacenter capabilities in
GCP by replicating existing
infrastructure architecture the goal of
this phase is to build a complete set of
the data center capability in in cloud
so any back-end support from on-premise
no longer need it and then obviously the
lastly phase three is where we migrate
on prim customers and data to GCP and
retire the data center one thing that we
noticed that is not all customers will
go through the complete cloud migration
journey rather we commonly adopt the
hybrid architecture due to this reason
we selected our lessons and learned from
our customers who are currently in phase
one and two for today while we are
executing our migration approach we
identified and selected five common
topics that we learned form from our
customers for today's session first lift
and shift and lift and what we'll
discuss around the beauty of the lift
and shift and then the thrill of
transform
there are many shiny objects and topics
in the cloud and we wanted to share a
few examples around how we address them
second data sense data center mr. cloud
one of the key benefits of adopting
cloud is managed services to reduce the
operation of infrastructure for example
all the specific versions of the open
source may get supported as part of the
managed services and we'll discuss that
Discovery's and dependency our lessons
learned from our discovery process
around what are the downstream
dependencies how we can approach that
deployment strategy will discuss around
short-term and long-term strategy around
automation and how we are deploying
infrastructure to automate or not to
automate is the current key question
around that finally the testing approach
testing approach between hybrid and full
stack the decision on testing approach
to the service in the dependency
test in the hybrid mode or doing an
individual unit testing and put it
together for full integration testing
that being said I'll pass to the pattern
to soiree for additional details for
each topic for our lessons Thank You
Dylan alright
hi everyone nice to meet you my name is
Swati Iyengar mashter teach at cloud
engineer at Google so I'm going to talk
about aspiration versus reality so to
start out with lift and shift can mean
many different things to many different
people and organizations for example
lift and shift can be taking everything
that you have in your on premise and
plopping it right into the cloud lift
and shift can mean taking what you have
in on-premises and taking advantage of
service some services in the cloud such
as the managed services that Dylan had
mentioned or some of our big data
solutions or a lift and shift can mean
taking what you have in on-premises
completely changing in a reap LAT
forming it to take advantage of a
completely new technology stack that
being said it could be kubernetes engine
it could be appengine it could be
managed instance groups just depends on
on how you want to move your technology
stack so there's a lot of different
options here and it can have many
different meanings that being said how
do you decide which approach to take
when you're going through a lift and
shift you may look at your existing
on-premise stack and see how many
different moving parts there are maybe
you have 80 or hundreds of microservices
and so there's a lot of different moving
parts in how you're implemented today
and then you take a look at your
application stack how complex it is how
many different technologies is it using
today and on-premises and how will that
translate to the cloud are your
applications ready and then you gauge
how much uncertainty is there is are you
moving one two
to applications where you have a really
good understanding of what the entire
stack looks like and how that'll look in
the cloud or are you dealing with
hundreds of services you may have some
legacy stuff sitting in the application
stack and you're not quite sure what
that's going to look like at the end of
the day the other input to consider is
time line do you have a few months to do
this lift and shift or do you have a few
years and that can mean many different
things and lastly what's your risk
appetite right when you're making this
lift and shift how much risk do you want
to take on initially considering all
these different factors and taking a
look at your technology aspirations and
where you want to take your technology
stack but then also what are the
business use cases and how does that map
to the approach that you want to take it
could be a pure lift and shift to begin
with and then a transformation later on
or it could be taking on the whole
transition all at once all right so
let's take a look at this example
application stack better customer had
and this is just a part of the stack so
they had 62 ad micro-services in a
global mesh per into 60 to 80 per region
you're looking at a full stack including
Apache Tomcat for the front end Redis
for caching data flow zookeeper and my
sequel for for data storage Hadoop and
much much more it was the entire kitchen
sink there there was a lot in there and
given that given that there were you
know several micro services and a very
and very complex application stack and a
lot of different moving pieces they
decided on approach to take a pure lift
and shift as much as possible of course
there's always differences right because
operating in your on-premise data center
is not exactly the same as operating in
the cloud you're moving to
software-defined networking versus
having Hardware networking
you're looking at other differences such
as the way your your access controls
work and how the managed services work
so there will be some some differences
still the pure lift and shift was what
this customer journey started with so
the data center meeting the cloud what
does this mean what does this look like
when you start this transformation in
this journey so to start with there is a
few different things to think about for
example when you're moving to a managed
service it's beautiful right with the
click of a button you get you get
backups you can in the case of cloud SQL
easily configure read replicas you can
go ahead and what else had operate in
multiple zones have your data data be
held in multiple zones for higher
availability and you have SLA s and
someone's managing the service for you
it's it's beautiful it comes with all
the bells and whistles but at the same
time you need to evaluate how you're
using that software and your on-premises
today
and how is that going to fit into this
managed service there may be a few
differences for one there could be
differences in terms of maybe how much
data you're holding in one instance and
on-premises and differences in what that
data that can be held the maximum amount
of data that can be held in an instance
in the the managed service there could
be differences in terms of how you're
accessing the service in terms of how
you can access it as a managed service
so a lot of things to think about when
deciding your approach what else does it
mean so in your on-premise environment
it may have evolved over time where you
had a number of things maybe for logging
and monitoring
you have your own in-house solutions you
may be running various other solutions
like check MK Nagios Splunk data dog you
name it and then when you move to the
cloud you may want to kind of
look at everything that you're running
and how you're configured to
troubleshoot in production today and on
premise and think okay if I'm gonna
centralize my logging and my monitoring
for ease of troubleshooting what is that
going to look like how am I going to
make sure that the format is the same
and that all the logs that were
available in my on premise are going to
be there in the centralized logging
solution so there's a large level of
effort that goes into that to make sure
that aside from moving your services
over your operationally ready the other
piece of it is to read the benefits of
some of the key features in the cloud
for example auto scaling of your
resources and Auto healing you may be
moving to a platform that has dynamic IP
addresses right where if an instance
because um becomes unhealthy for example
in a managed instance group let's say
the manage distance group will go ahead
and delete the instance and then
recreate it but it's going to come back
as a new virtual machine with a
different IP address out of a specified
subnet of course and the question is
from an Operations perspective are you
are you ready for that or your
troubleshooting playbooks updated to be
comfortable with that and or do you
still have the need to ssh into a
virtual machine to do your
troubleshooting and make sure that the
logs that you expect are there that
things are working as expected
so there's a lot that has to change with
respect to to the operations as well and
then there's a concept of pets versus
cattle how many of you ever heard this
term before pets versus cattle so you
have your pets right your pets at home
you take care of them you love them if
something's wrong with them you go ahead
and help them feel better and you might
you know put a little bandaid on
or maybe give them additional resources
and then there's the cattle so when you
think about cattle each and every wolf
cattle is identical and if you have
greater workloads you're just gonna
scale up the number of cattle that you
have so that's a philosophy a difference
and of course you can have either one in
the cloud you can bring pets or unique
instances over into the cloud where
let's say each individual VM has its own
configuration and you need to keep it
alive and run with only that VM and not
have it be automatically deleted you
could do that with the technology such
as individual VMs or unmanaged instance
groups but you may want to take
advantage of some of the auto healing
and auto scaling that we had talked
about earlier and then take the Caddo
approach to take advantage of some
platforms like for example imagine
instance groups or where it could be
scaling up your paws and kubernetes
engine so it's a little bit of a
question of what are your applications
look like today how are you
operationally addressing the need for
additional VMs or resources and how can
you support that in GCP or in the cloud
so in addition to that there's a mapping
of people and processes of course is
everyone comfortable with supporting
everything in production in the cloud
and looking at your solutions for things
like secrets how are you doing your
secrets management today and how is that
going to change when you move to the
cloud how are you managing her SSL
Certificates and how is that going to
change and the list continues so here's
an example customer on-premise footprint
that we that we worked with and they
have a number of different data centers
in multiple regions that were globally
distributed and connected by a
point-to-point links or VPNs and when
they moved to the cloud the idea was to
bring up adjacent data centers in GCP so
what does that look like from
architectural perspective so here for
example you have a shared V PC network
on GCP which allows you to have a global
network and so if the resources within
your cloud or the VMS need to
communicate they can communicate for the
services on the private IP space and
then they wanted to support you have for
the interim some tools or applications
that are still located on premise or
perhaps some of the data is still on
premise until you complete the migration
then in that case you
we set up dedicated interconnects
between the adjacent regions at about 10
gigabits per second so that's what the
overall foundation look like and forgot
to mention that with the shared V PC the
benefit there is all your resources can
sit on the same network but each of the
services that are in the resources can
sit in their own projects and the access
controls can be can be controlled at the
project level while they still leverage
the same network width which is
beautiful okay so we kind of talked
about the horizontal architecture now
let's talk about our discovery period
for looking at these applications and
services vertically so here we wanted to
take a holistic approach and we learned
early on that in order to take a
holistic approach we actually wanted to
lay the foundation as we did and then
also do a deep dive in every single
application or at least the significant
ones so we did this for about 45 or so
applications vertically asking questions
such as what's the function of the
service at a basic level who are the
consumers where are they located
so that way we can make sure that we are
able to facilitate the connectivity for
example are the services communicating
internally are they external consumers
are they on premises with the
steamer are they within the same region
are they globally located so there's a
lot of variations here and then it also
helped us understand when we would test
eventually what that would look like and
then the other question was what are the
downstream dependencies from here who
needs to talk to what downstream and
that way from a networking perspective
we could make sure that it was set up to
enable that as well and then looking at
the data layer what do the backends look
like today
and on-premises are they shared
should they be shared when they move to
the cloud or are they actually using
completely different tables and it would
be ok to split them up and put the
individual data instances with the
individual services so a lot of
questions there and other questions such
as does the data need to be directly
accessible will it be accessed from
on-prem and additionally speaking are
there any specific security requirements
because you may not discover them at and
when looking at the entire architecture
but when doing a deep dive on the
service you come across some of these
use cases like perhaps you have services
communicating internally and they're
using HTTPS and the other question is at
the deepest level
how are your health checks on your
services working today how do you
identify when a service is unhealthy are
you just looking at the issue to be
response code are you looking for that
plus a string how does that work in GCP
or do your health checks and GCP work
exactly the same way so these are just
an example or a subset of the questions
that we looked at for each of the
services to make sure that we recognized
what was unknown early on and identified
it so that way we can look at it so
other results of the discovery what came
out of it so after going through this
deep type discovery we actually fed the
results back into the overall arc
and adjusted her architecture a-courtin
accordingly develop criteria for
determining on a per service basis which
load balancer to use for example because
there are a few different flavors within
the platform determining how we're gonna
do dns resolution during this
split-brain period figuring out other
things such as how are we going to do
our secrets management how do how are we
going to split up our data instances for
each of the services are we gonna put
one service in a project is this
currently shared data going to be split
up into two so we went from there and
one of the most important things that we
came up with was a blueprint a blueprint
for if you are going to lift and shift
application why per this customers
requirements and their architecture and
the individual applications requirements
what does that look like right what's
the criterion what are all the decisions
that we need to make when we're doing
that lift and shift so we came up with a
comprehensive blueprint that we could
follow to really scale when we're
working with tens and
50 to 270 or so micro services which was
really key so that way when they were
lifted and shifted they were lifted and
shifted consistently other things that
we looked at was we took their
on-premise load balancer and did a deep
dive in analysis on the features and
capabilities there that were being used
today to see how those would map over to
capabilities in the cloud and then we
also looked at how individual teams
would access the applications and how we
provision that and the biggest piece the
biggest piece that came out of this was
the known unknown so you have the
unknown unknown which is kind of like
this nebulous this nebulous thing which
was just like this horrible feeling but
at least at the end of this we had
surfaced a number of known unknowns that
then we could take and tackle and
solution for
so that way we didn't have surprises
later on that was a key a key result
that really came out of this and now
let's move to deployment strategy now
that we talked about lifting and
shifting the individual applications so
there's a couple options here right when
you're going to deploy into the cloud
you can either take everything that you
have you know spin up some VMs spin up
the platform move your data over or move
your image over kind of get things going
and you're on your way right you can
start testing and then get to production
the other option so you know the other
option there is to automate it automate
it right that with a lot of additional
benefits such as if you automate in this
scenario there was multiple data centers
and we wanted to deploy consistently
across each of the data centers so by
automating it and taking an automated
approach terraform we could consistently
do that across four different data
centers so what might be some initial
investment and spending the time to to
code resulted in longer-term speed and
inconsistency and simplicity and then
also if there was ever an emergency
scenario and you needed it to do a
redeploy you could go ahead and do the
redeploy because you have the code there
you're not worried about sitting there
and spinning up everything individually
so this approach nicely lent itself to
multiple data center deployments and
that's the approach that we took okay so
now the testing approach the big
question in testing this in this
scenario was there was everything
on-premises there was a global mesh
services each of which were being
deployed in every single region for the
most part the question is do we test in
a hybrid mode meaning that we bring up
one service and then do integration
testing with the other services in
on-premise to verify that it's working
as expected
or and do we go ahead and come up with
the full stack and GCP and then do a
testing so by taking one service and
bringing it up and testing with on-prem
that required a few different things one
is reconfiguring the int environment on
premise
so we're polluting that environment and
the second downfall there is that you
actually not testing what's going to go
in production you're testing a different
configuration than will actually be
deployed at the end of the day so you
may miss things in terms of what's not
really working together from an
integration perspective so for those
reasons we took the approach of actually
testing doing development in parallel
bringing up each of the service says I'm
doing unit testing and then going ahead
and testing in full stock because at the
end of the day that is what will be
deployed in in production and it you
have a clearer entrance and exit
criteria and cano yeah you know we
should be good to go
I still be working when we get to
production now I wanted to talk about
the passport acceptors going through all
of that what came out of this some new
great guiding principles and the first
being lift and shift it's really
critical to have a discussion early on
and define and make sure everyone is on
the same page as far as what a lift and
shift means to them is that the lifted
shift in the purest form lift and shift
with some transformation a completely
platform a lift and shift and then a
transform what does it mean and then as
you're going through your your migration
process when you come to a decision look
back and say or are you staying true to
that or maybe you need a pivot on that
initial decision
I'm really kind of writing that down and
taking a look at it every now and then
the other is managed service preferred
right you get all the beautiful bells
and whistles when you're using a managed
service so really that's a nice way to
go as long as your application will fit
in it right
in order for you to use a managed
service if you want to drive the shiny
car your application needs to fit in it
so it's just verifying that you meet
that criteria and the other is to take a
holistic approach so think about the
architecture at a horizontal level but
then also do the diligence to do the
vertical deep dive so that way you can
foresee what the known unknown are and
discover anything legacy that's sitting
there that you may need to do deeper
investigation on in the fourth as far as
deployment strategy is especially when
you're dealing with the complex um
environment with multiple data centers
and if you want a way to easily redeploy
an emergency scenario spend the time and
automate to move faster over time so
it's automate to move fast and then as
far as the testing approach it's a full
stack wherever possible or whatever is
going to look closest to your production
environment and in this case that was
full stack testing as opposed to a
hybrid testing great and I'm gonna call
my colleague Dylan back up here and this
is a large part of the team that was
working on this migration project it was
an entire team and honestly this many
more people - we couldn't fit everyone
on this slide and I'm it's really a big
team effort there's a lot of moving
parts and them a lot of expertise needed
to - literature
[Music]